bah la première des choses c'est de ne
pas faire de régime puisque on estime
que un Français sur deux et soit en
surpoids soit obèse donc ça veut dire
qu'il y a un problème dans la façon dont
on mange et dans la façon de ce qu'on
fait ou ce qu'on ne fait pas et puis on
a tous expérimenter ça si on fait un
sondage à main levée dans le public pour
savoir qui a déjà tenté un régime je
pense que de nombreuses personnes vont
lever la main et si on leur pose la même
question avez-vous réussi à maintenir
cette perte de poids très peu vont lever
la main les études sont claires lorsque
vous faites un régime et bien seul une
personne sur 5 arrivera à maintenir son
poids sur le long terme ça veut dire que
4 sur 5 vont échouer et la plupart du
temps qu'est-ce qui se passe on a du
poids on continue à manger
la première erreur c'est qu'on va se
restreindre on pense que pour perdre du
poids il faut manger moins il faut
manger mieux il faut manger différemment
lorsque vous mettez en restriction
calorique imaginez que vous souhaitez le
dîner vous dites moi je veux perdre du
poids le dîner je le prends pas ou je
mange une soupe vous allez économiser
des calories bien sûr 500 kcal et vous
allez penser perdre du poids au début ça
va marcher et puis au bout d'un moment
votre organisme il va se dire mais il
est en train de me stresser là il va se
mettre en la famine donc il va stocker
et donc il va prendre toute l'énergie du
moindre repas que vous allez manger et
par conséquent cette perte de poids elle
va s'estomper dans le temps vous allez
voir que ça ne marche plus vous allez
craquer est-ce que vous serez frustré
vous allez remanger je vais défoncer des
miches locaux et les feuilles de yoyo et
vous reprenez du poivre même un ou deux
kilos supplémentaires et puis au bout
d'un moment on recommence et ainsi de
suite et on arrive régime après régime à
perdre du poids en reprendre perdre du
poids et on arrive 10 ans après en
faisant mes minces qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé et donc l'idée c'est de ne pas
faire de régime et qui ne comprendre
qu'il est possible de perdre du poids en
mangeant plus mais en mangeant mieux
alors vous avez vous expliquer ça dans
l'instant mangez plus pour gagner plus
pour manger mieux et pour payer moins
d'électricité Kelly alors est-ce qu'il
est vrai Jimmy parce que ça va dans ton
sens ce qu'il est vrai que lorsqu'on
mange on perd du poids parce qu'en fait
on mange tous les travailler l'estomac
ça fait perdre des calories parce qu'en
fait ça nous demande un effort c'est ça
en fait il suffit de manger des choses
qui ne sont pas caloriques ont peur du
poids il y a plusieurs éléments si on
prend vous savez on parle souvent du
microbiote la flore intestinale
au microbiote de personnes c'est la
flore intestinale la flore digestive
c'est les bactéries qu'on a dans le
ventre qui nous permettent de digérer
mais pas que si on analyse le microbiote
des personnes qui sont obèses et qu'on
compare à celui qui ne sont pas obèses
le microbiote est totalement différent
quels sont les conséquences la première
extrêmement simple lorsque une personne
obèse mange un repas et qu'une personne
non obèse mange le même repas et bien la
personne obèse elle va stocker plus de
calories un repas équivalent parce que
le microbiote est perturbé donc ça va
dépendre de ce que vous mangez et il y a
une clé toute simple et bien c'est
d'avoir une alimentation riche en fibres
si vous mangez des fibres vous n'allez
pas grossir et vous allez aux toilettes
de Kellogg's régulateur de transit les
fibres ça marche dans cette marque il
peut y avoir des fibres mais
c'est bon
légumineuses les pois chiches les
lentilles ça veut dire que tu as plus de
meuf quoi parce que
dans une étude absolument incroyable on
a proposé aux gens de faire deux choses
un groupe de patients 150 g de
légumineuses tous les soirs et un autre
groupe de patients 500 kg calories de
mois ça veut dire que dans un y en a qui
ont plus chier que les autres hein parce
que ça régule correctement dans un
groupe on mange moi dans un groupe on
mange plus et bien finalement les deux
au bout de deux mois ont perdu 2,5 cm de
tour de taille et pourtant dans un
groupe on a plus mangé ça veut dire
qu'on peut manger plus et perdre du
poids encore une fois c'est manger
différemment et arrêter de croire qu'il
faut s'affamer pour perdre du poids
cette méthode ne marche pas alors je
vais me faire le porte-parole des gens
qui sont un peu ventripotent comme moi
est-ce que c'est pas un peu facile quand
on a pas de problème de poids de dire
aux gens qui ont 10 20 30 kilos de trop
dans les inquiétez pas faites pas de
régime parce qu'on a besoin quand même
d'un choc psychologique au départ d'un
d'une motivation si on se dit qu'on va
perdre un kilo tous les mois ou tous les
deux mois c'est un peu deux éléments le
premier c'est la culpabilité les
personnes qui sont en surpoids souvent
leur fait croire que c'est de leur faute
or c'est multifactoriel la génétique
donc l'hérédité l'environnement on a
parlé du micro et c'est pas simplement
ce qu'ils ont dans l'assiette maintenant
il faut aussi être indulgent avec
soi-même souvent le poids qu'on a pris
on a pris sur des mois des années 10 15
ans c'est pas comme ça le poids qu'on a
pris en 15 ans on voudrait le perdre 1 3
6 mois c'est pas viable donc en fait en
se disant en changeant de paradigme
l'objectif qu'on devrait avoir et qui
est très modeste et ben c'est 5 % de
poids de son poids en 6 mois c'est vers
si vous faites 80 kg c'est simplement 4
kg 4 kg vous allez me dire c'est pas
beaucoup mais c'est la seule façon de
changer vos habitudes au jour le jour
pour tenir sur le long terme tous les
régimes restrictifs vous allez voir à
manger que des pommes et ben manger un
seul aliment ça va marcher au tout début
mais vous allez perdre quoi c'est du
muscle de l'eau vous avez pas perdre de
gras et dès lors que vous allez remanger
normalement vous allez reprendre tout le
poids comme les régimes ne fonctionnent
pas il faut encore une fois voir
l'alimentation différemment et ne pas se
frustrer souvent à dire je vais éliminer
tous les fast food tous les graines
parce que c'est pas un problème de se
faire plaisir
une fois par semaine
un jour par semaine 6
de d'annuler tous les régimes que tous
les diététiciens même très connus pour
sortie des livres tu es en train de nous
dire que c'est de la
c'est que tu vas perdre mais tu vas
reprendre exactement regardez les études
toutes les études quand on fait un
régime c'est sur trois à six mois ça
marche 3 à 6 mois mais il n'y a aucune
étude qui montre un régime efficace sur
le long terme ça ne marche pas
il faudrait que ce soit un style de vie
alors pratiquer du jeûne intermittent
par exemple ça veut dire qu'on va pas
que des jeunes pendant quoi deux trois
jours
intermittent c'est de jeûner attention
ce n'est pas le jeune prolonger que
certains naturopathes vont proposer pour
guérir des cancers ça c'est des fausses
croyances et c'est dangereux mais de
sauter le petit déjeuner qui n'est pas
un repas obligatoire sauf chez les
enfants de prendre un des jeunes dîner
et ben déjà rien que ça on peut perdre
du poids et réguler sa faim pour faire
la distinction entre la fin de l'envie
de manger on mange trop le matin au
petit déjeuner le déjeuner le on va
grignoter le dîner il y a aucun moment
on laisse son tube digestif et on ne
sait même plus reconnaître la sensation
de faim de l'envie de manger donc le
jeune intermittent ça peut aider un gros
slogan qui dit qu'il faut pas grignoter
entre les repas et moi j'ai envie de
dire alors à ce moment grignote quand
il a raison les repas c'est vrai
qu'est-ce que tu fais non non là je
rigole pendant 2 minutes par exemple si
vous mangez des amandes une poignée
d'amandes pour le pour le beaucoup
d'amande donc les amandes vous avez le
droit de manger souvent dit deux ou
trois amandes c'est faux 20 à 25 à bien
sûr pour le goûter c'est très bon pour
le sport
les fruits secs c'est les fruits secs
franchement beaucoup de fruits secs mais
les alors je croyais que c'est quand
même très sucré parce que c'est très
concentré en sucre mais les amandes
c'est des oléagineux et bien rien que ça
vous allez apprendre des oléagineux une
famille comme les noix notamment les
noisettes les amandes c'est du bon gras
qui est protège en plus des maladies
cardiovasculaires et qui en plus donc il
est possible de manger amenez-moi de se
faire plaisir sans prendre de poids
pour vous il y a un aliment si on avait
qu'à retenir c'est la pomme est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi la
pomme c'est si miraculeux parce que la
pomme la pomme déjà la pomme c'est le
jardin d'Eden ok la pomme
ok la pomme tout ça avec moi j'adore
puis moi je connaissais j'adorais la
Golden je connaissais une actrice sucrée
[Rires]
si vous remplacez tous les gâteaux
industriels et crème glacé les glaces
par des fruits que vous allez manger à
volonté souvent on va diaboliser le
sucre que contient la pomme ça pose
aucun problème manger deux ou trois
pommes à la place de gâteau vous n'allez
jamais prendre du poids vous allez en
perdre parce que
en fait il faut bien comprendre que
quand on mange un aliment il y a le
plaisir instantané il faut qu'on garde
mais il faut bien comprendre que chaque
aliment qu'on a il va être digéré par
notre tube digestif notre microbiote va
changer au travers de cet aliment je
n'ai rien certainement microbes il va y
avoir des effets secondaires
donc en fait c'est revenir au-delà de
l'alimentation plaisir uniquement c'est
de se dire que la pomme elle est riche
par exemple je vous parlais des fibres
une fille qui s'appelle la pectine la
pectine elle va former un gel dans votre
tube digestif pour protéger votre
intestin et protéger votre microbiote et
des études ont montré notamment chez
l'animal que la pectine et que la pomme
peut permettre au cerveau de produire de
nouvelles cellules c'est absolument
incroyable et que ça protège aussi le
foie des patients qui vont consommer un
peu d'alcool ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
faut boire uniquement de l'alcool mais
se dire que au travers d'une
alimentation simple et équilibrée sans
régime sans recette extraordinaire il
est possible de perdre du poids miracle
tout en mangeant sans s'affamer et Jimmy
on peut la faire en compote quand on en
a marre on va perdre déjà on va chauffer
le fruit parce que quand on fait une
compote on est passé pour les plus de
110 ans les enfants dans les compotes
ils en mangent régulièrement
de la satiété parce qu'on perd des
fibres donc si un enfant ou si vous
voulez vous aimez pas du tout manger des
pommes bien c'est mieux la compote que
mais si jamais vous vous devez
privilégier quelque chose merci plutôt
la vraie pomme parce qu'il y a de la
mâche il y a de la société une pomme
vous allez la manger en quelques minutes
la compote en deux secondes les 25
minutes pour manger une pomme mais ça
met du temps et ça ça provoque de la
société bien sûr qu'on va commettre
c'est de s'asseoir et de manger on va
être repu on aura plus faim alors que
souvent on va gober un repas en 3
minutes et au bout d'un moment ben le
cerveau il a pas eu le temps de
comprendre qu'il est temps de s'arrêter
de manger pour pas vous alors je vais
vous expliquer c'est beaucoup de fort
donc forcément la nutrition c'est très
important et Jimmy est un ami mais là je
suis en colère parce que en vrai
Jimmy en vrai Jimmy là vous venez pour
nous dire que on peut manger tant qu'on
veut donc ce qu'il a dit
il faut manger différemment non tu l'as
dit tant qu'on veut tant que ce sont des
aliments
c'est une fois par semaine moi j'ai un
médecin qui m'avait dit en gros quand
c'est bon c'est pas bon donc tout ce qui
est sain vous pouvez y aller mais
forcément les gens qui grossissent
qu'est-ce qu'ils aiment les pommes de
terre le nutella les massacres le soir
la pomme de terre alors que la pomme de
terre ça coûte pas cher
ça coûte pas cher c'est compliqué
ça rassasie et une pomme que vous faites
une une patate que vous allez faire au
four elle fait pas grossir non en
revanche si vous découpez la pomme de
terre et vous en faites des frites et
que vous faites cuire ces frites
vous les faites au four et bien ça
change d'un coup l'index électrique une
fois par semaine vous regardez
d'ailleurs regardez sur les emballages
lorsque vous faites des courses au
supermarché vous pouvez avoir vous savez
le nutriscore l'aliment en fonction
nutritionnelles bien sûr certains
paquets de frites vous avez a et pour
voir les frites ça dépend tu fais ah et
bah oui ça marche si vous faites au four
les frites au four ne posent pas de
problème en revanche quand on va prendre
ses frites et qu'on va les mettre dans
de l'huile et bien là vous allez prendre
du poids donc il est possible de manger
des frites pas tous les jours parce que
mais les faire cuire différemment c'est
une autre astuce qu'on peut proposer
pour ça qu'on dit souvent aussi va te
faire cuire un œuf parce qu'il faut
faire comment tu le fais cuire et fais
grossir ou pas parce que c'est
maintenant que le corps de cet été le
corps de cet été se prépare maintenant
pour quelques-uns ici c'est mort
ça que pour Raymond mon ami voilà il va
encore passer cet été en T-shirt à la
piscine vous avez beaucoup
franchement frère si moi je perds pas de
c'est que même moi je suis dégoûté parce
que avec tout le sport que je sais que
je mets je mérite mieux si match je
mérite mieux je suis désolé non je
mérite mieux j'y mets moi-même comment
ça se fait alors frérot je dois être le
mec sans charrier je dois faire et je te
le dis je dois faire on va pas se mentir
je dois faire 12 heures de sport par
semaine comment ça se fait que je suis
dégueulasse alors déjà il faut faire
attention parce que souvent on se
focalise sur le poids sur la balance le
poids sur la balance
dans votre corps je me sens très bien
masse musculaire le muscle pèse plus
lourd que la graisse donc si vous êtes
musclé parce que vous courez beaucoup
vous jouez donc forcément ça pèse plus
de poids et donc on a tendance je fais
tout oui mais arrêtez aussi de courir
c'est ça et ben par exemple courir
lorsqu'on court et qu'on se dit je vais
faire un footing d'une demi-heure
souvent on va se dire je faire du sport
une fois par semaine je vais aller
courir pendant 30 minutes alors toute la
semaine on essaie dentaire on fait pas
grand chose et le dimanche on se
réveille on fait 30 minutes 30 minutes
de course moyenne c'est environ 350 kcal
350 kg 4 c'est rien c'est une pomme de
pizza c'est une part de pizza
il est en fait si vous l'écoutez Jimmy
ne courait pas régime restez chez vous
démontez vous
le fait
de l'activité physique autrement tout ce
que vous faites assis vous pouvez faire
debout par exemple vous allez brûler 3
c'est plus de kilos calories moi je
brûle là tous les soirs
je suis derrière un camion toute la
journée c'est vrai que par exemple si on
regarde la défense énergétique d'un
agriculteur un agriculteur il va pas la
salle de sport il fait pas de foot quoi
que ce soit et il est bien tous les
jours il dépense l'équivalent de 2500
kcal juste par son activité physique
parce qu'il va marcher parce qu'il va
porter des trucs tu as raison parce
qu'il va monter des escaliers et non
c'est à nous faut que je fasse l'amour
est dans au travers de gestes simple du
quotidien se dire bah si je dois monter
4 étages peut-être que je vais en faire
deux avec l'ascenseur et deux avec
l'escalier je vais marcher un petit peu
plus je vais dépenser tout le monde tu
vas bloquer l'ascenseur à deux tu dis
attendez les deux autres je l'ai fait en
marchant
il a raison mais c'est aussi une
question de mental aussi parce que quand
tu te lèves à 5h du matin à 9h tu as
envie de déboîter une côte de bœuf tu as
envie de manger quand ça c'est vrai je
travaille en horaires décalé et celui
qui est probablement le plus pénible et
difficile pour l'organisme c'est
Guillaume et Guillaume et Raymond ils
sont heureux de nuit ou à cheval avec
les matinales et bien on prend du poids
parce que quoi qu'on veuille quoi qu'on
dise la journée on doit être objectifs
et la nuit on doit dormir donc c'est
vrai que quand on travaille notamment la
nuit on est plus exposé un risque de
surpoids et d'obésité parce que nos
hormones qui régulent notamment la fin
et la satiété sont perturbés donc il
faut aussi se dire que notre métier a
une influence et que vous n'êtes pas
responsable de cette prise de poids bien
sûr et par conséquent il faut être
indulgent sur les petits changements du
quotidien
pour changer une habitude on dit souvent
c'est 21 jours c'est pas 21 jours c'est
bien plus dans une étude très simple on
a proposé aux gens de changer ne
serait-ce qu'une seule habitude soit de
manger un fruit à une heure fixe soit de
faire un peu de sport il a fallu dans
cette étude entre 20 et 250 jours pour
la changer ça veut dire que en moyenne
il faut 66 jours pour changer une seule
habitude imaginez toutes les mauvaises
habitudes qu'on a accumulé au cours
d'une vie c'est pareil du jour au
lendemain on a claquement de doigts les
changer donc soyez indulgent avec
vous-même soyez patient et c'est la
seule façon de perdre du poids moi j'ai
perdu 12 kg
je les ai perdu et je les reprends pas
et je me frustre pas alors est-ce que
tu peux nous faire le test du
sandwichs on parle régime se privé de
quelque chose c'est bien un truc moi le
vin depuis le 18 octobre j'ai pas vu une
goutte de vin je vous ai je faisais
[Applaudissements]
on va pas la gueule
95 j'ai perdu est-ce que 7 kg mais je
les ai vraiment bien perdu et la forme
et là tu as plus envie de boire
est-ce que ce petit silence merci une
réponse mais c'est important de le dire
parce que la dépendance à l'alcool alors
je dis pas que vous étiez dépendant mais
la dépression
péjorative l'alcoolisme la dépendance à
l'alcool est une maladie les gens sont
malades et lorsque comme vous décidez
d'arrêter de boire et de vous
accompagner peut-être par quelqu'un ou
pas vous féliciter donc bravo à vous
parce que pour votre santé et pour votre
poids d'une façon et bien voilà
attention la bu d'alcool donc bravo
d'avoir perdu tu vois parce que l'alcool
c'est très calorique c'est très très
alcool bien sûr prendre du poids la
dernière fois j'ai bu hein Virgin mojito
les Moctets sont très sucrés très sucrés
ils sont hyper sucré
et en plus il y a beaucoup de sucre
Jean-Marie en tout cas tu sais que tu as
changé de tête quoi
bien sûr son visage a changé ah oui le
le tous les petits vaisseaux qui se
mettent sur le nez des alcooliques tu
vois c'est quoi ça comment ça se passe
comment s'il avait une fraise là comme
ça ici il y avait une Tagada ce qu'on
appelle une rosacée peut-être favorisé
par la prise d'alcool c'est comme
uniquement lié à l'alcool attention
toutes les personnes qui ont le nez un
peu éclaté rose ne sont pas dépendantes
à l'alcool c'est aussi une vraie maladie
indépendante merci alors le sandwich
pour le 50 nuage à 20h30 que la
production achetée quasiment 300 grammes
hyper lourd ah il est lourd je le vois
lourd et c'est on peut pas citer la
marque mais c'est la marque il coûte le
plus cher et c'est la marque tout le
monde connaît dans les petits emballages
au thon qui commence
un D ind et ça reste des mots il y en a
plein bon bref c'était la marque peu
importe et donc ce sandwich là si vous
le mangez ça n'a aucun intérêt parce que
vous allez prendre du poids et vous
n'allez pas rassasier pourquoi kiffer
non mais qui fait quoi il y en a qui
fait dedans regardez on va ouvrir ce
sandwich j'adore les sandwichs quand on
regarde ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur
franchement c'est honteux de vendre ça
aux français quand on regarde la
quantité regardez de rien en fait que
vous avez là dans un sandwich c'est
scandaleux
il y a quoi une bouchée c'est la grande
version la deuxième si je vide si je
gratte
vous avez allez à tout casser voilà j'ai
quasiment éclaté là sur l'autoroute
c'est 18 € sur l'autoroute et ça coûte
cher c'est vrai regardez on a ça ouais
de protéines et beaucoup de légumes vous
avez quoi c'est du pain et en plus c'est
du mauvais pain blanc ou du pain
viennois qui est bourré dessus donc sur
l'instant votre estomac il est rempli
parce que là mine de rien vous avez une
demi-baguette qui est dans l'estomac et
vous n'en pouvez plus mais le problème
c'est que vous allez avoir un pic de
sucre à cause de ça parce que ça c'est
de sucre uniquement vous n'allez pas
avoir les fibres dont je vous ai parlé
tout à l'heure vous n'allez pas avoir
assez de protéines et vous allez avoir
faim alors vous aurez dépensé de
l'argent vous serez pas rassasié et vous
allez prendre du poids l'idée c'est soit
de faire du jeûne intermittent en disant
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas le temps de
manger d'accord je préfère assumer et ne
pas sauter le repas je me dis
aujourd'hui à midi j'ai pas le temps de
manger des choses pas bonnes je ne mange
pas ou alors je me prépare une vraie
salade que je vais blinder je vais
prendre du thon des œufs vous la blindez
repu vous n'aurez plus faim et en plus
de ça et ce sera meilleur pour votre
santé parce que tout ce que je vous
propose c'est à la fois ok vous allez
perdre du poids mais aussi pour votre
santé cardiovasculaire pour le diabète
bien sûr arthrose pas uniquement pour la
silhouette parce que moi quand je vous
donne ça c'est pas un critère esthétique
qu'on a un peu de bide c'est pas la fin
du monde on s'en fiche c'est de se dire
que le surpoidité ce sont des maladies
qui entraînent plein d'autres maladies
et que si on veut être en bonne santé il
faut faire attention à ce qu'on met dans
son assiette
on parle souvent des calories est-ce que
par exemple si on mange que deux
sandwichs comme ça par jour avec que de
l'eau rien d'autre on est quand même en
dessous des calories j'imagine dont on a
besoin on passe à perdre du poids
alors ça va dépendre de chacun
en fait les calories ne sont pas
équivalentes si je vous propose un repas
composé de d'avocat un œuf des œufs des
épinards ce que vous voulez un truc ou
peut-être calorique avec des amandes en
plus et qu'à l'inverse je vous propose
exactement le même repas en termes de
calories avec ce genre de sandwich avec
le sandwich vous allez prendre du poids
vous allez grossir et en plus avoir une
influence sur vos humeurs
fast food donc l'alimentation
elle favorise la dépression et à
l'inverse
que vous allez manger avec des produits
simples de base sans cuisiner et bien ça
permet d'avoir une meilleure humeur et
de perdre du poids attention avec les
calories on parle souvent de économiser
les calories toutes les calories ne se
valent pas bien sûr les calories de
l'avocat ne veulent pas les calories
d'une médecin
ultra transformé par exemple Jimmy tu es
d'accord qu'on est pas égaux ah bien sûr
les trucs tu as des gens qui ont fait
exactement la même chose qui sont secs
comme un coup de trucs
génétique microbiote et puis il faut
aussi rappeler que dans la vie d'une
femme par exemple il y a plein de
périodes de la vie et des
bouleversements hormonaux bien sûr à la
puberté lorsqu'on a un enfant c'est moi
un accouchement de la contraception
en fait il faut que je dis à la perte de
poids et la prise gardez en tête un
exemple tout simple les sportifs de haut
niveau arrêtent leur carrière à 35 ans
bien sûr maximum pourquoi parce que leur
corps change il faut aussi accepter nous
quand vieillissant notre corps change et
qu'on soit peut-être plus indulgent un
peu plus de mal mais qu'on sent un peu
plus patient avec soi-même et qu'on peut
perdre du poids sans frustrer sans
contrainte merci Jimmy
[Applaudissements]